I thought we'd help our audience members  make a sale or connection by showing  some of their craigslist ads right here  on the show would that be nice  oh let's check out the first ad taken -  there we go  do you believe marijuana should be legal  in California let's get together get  high and do absolutely nothing about  [Applause]  need flavors I have over 10,000 saved in  my beer here's one hiring director seeks  serious actors for roles in small  independent art house film but goblins  12 19 11  here's one for hire 55 year-old man  who's also a 15 year old boy  [Applause]  here's one Colette you said you'd sleep  with me if I was the last man on earth  if everything goes according to plan by  Saturday night I will be and finally man  seeking wind for maximum sexiness  [Applause]  nice sexy move over Fabio yeah  Fabio who I say oh he got his thumb  stuck in the fan  you